une prime du personnel soignant qui
ressemble à une loterie les départements
les plus touchés par la crise sont a
priori les heureux gagnants
une somme déjà touchés par les agents de
l'hôpital public en île de france et les
eau de france les autres devraient la
recevoir au plus tard avec leurs
bulletins de paie du mois de juin
pour les autres départements 61 ans au
total
la prime est réduite à 500 euros petite
exception cependant pour les soignants
ayant travaillé dans un des 117 hôpitaux
ayant accueilli des patients transférés
dans ces départements
jugées moins affectés par la crise ce
sera au directeur d'établissement
d'arbitrés jusqu'à 40% du personnel
pourra être éligible aux 1500 euros
enfin quel que soit le département
la prime sera divisé par deux si le
soignant a été absent plus de 30 jours
entre le 1er mars et le 30 avril point
nombre les aides à domicile en première
ligne pendant le confinement ne
toucheront aucune prime l'état ayant
exclu les professions libérales du
dispositif
alors à défaut de l'aide gouvernementale
certains départements comme la meurthe
et moselle ont annoncé une prime de 1500
euros pour ces deux mille salariés de
l'ada domicile pour le reste des
professions libérales des organismes
privés ou des caisses de retraite se
substitueront également à l'aide
gouvernementale comme les chirurgiens
dentistes à hauteur de 4500 euros ou les
sages femmes qui recevront 1000 euros en
revanche les heures supplémentaires
durant cette période seront elles bien
majorée de 50% pour tous
mais si les primes font partie des
revendications du personnel soignant
bien d'autres au point de doléances
reste en suspens c'est actuellement ne
le débat soulevé au ségur de la santé
depuis le 25 mai objectif une
revalorisation pérenne des métiers de
soignants
[Musique]